all right hello everybody and welcome to
the fifth and final
basics of tkinter tutorial for python
three
so while this is the end of my basic
covering of what tkinter is uh you
should see it very much like my basic
covering of regular expressions was or
url lib uh was and all of that because
there's a whole lot of other things that
we can do obviously making windows is a
very vast topic and
you know i might come through and do
more of an intermediate or advanced
tkinter
not advanced decanter but
an expanded tkinter tutorial but really
my my goal here was really just to teach
you guys some of the basics of t-canter
how to add things to decanter
event handling with decanter and then
from there hopefully you can
you know look up various things you know
that you might be wanting to do and then
hopefully you can implement it rather
simply so
anyway uh with that what i want to do
here is show how we can display images
in tkinter
as well as
text okay so
with that let's go ahead and get started
what we're going to need immediately is
to do images we're going to need the
imaging an imaging library python 2
people will use
pill python imaging library
but a good second hand
imaging library is what's known as
pillow
and with python 3 i highly recommend
that's what we use so to get it uh you
can either go and download pillow you
know however you like your favorite way
to download things is or you can use
this website here if i remember to i'll
put a link for it in the description if
i forget remind me
and so we'll just search for pillow um i
guess i'll just click on this okay so
here we have pillow
get rid of that
and now we're looking for at least for
me i've got 64-bit and i'm using through
python 3.4 so you would want to download
that
and then when it's done downloading go
ahead and install it and then once
you've got it installed you're ready to
continue so if you're still waiting and
all that
go ahead and pause the video and then
restart the video once you have it
so once you have it uh how much you have
pillow uh installed what we're going to
do is you're going to come up here and
you're going to say from pil import
capital image
and then we're going to do image
tk so pay attention these are all caps
here capital i capital i capital t okay
now what we're going to do is we're
going to come over to
our
window initialization here and we'll
leave everything here um
and i think what we'll do is we'll edit
this
edit menu right and so right now our
edit menu doesn't do anything really
let's go ahead and save and run this
real quick
so
uh we have our file saved the save does
nothing we can click in it doesn't do
anything and then we have exit
and that exits and then we have this
undo but undo doesn't do anything either
so
um
we'll leave save there but instead of
undo let's say
uh instead we're going to call this show
image
and then we're going to say this is add
command right so add command
um
self oops i'm sorry uh command equals
self dot and let me make some space here
so
we edit this show image and then command
equals self
dot
show
capital img okay so if that show image
so this is gonna this is referring to a
function within our class okay
and then we're always passing through
you know frame through it
um
so command equals self that show image
when we do that
and then also let's go ahead and add
another command um
let me just we're just going to copy
this line paste this line and instead of
image text and then instead of show img
txt
okay
easy enough and then afterwards we add
that to our menu
um and that's it now we didn't want to
define self.show image install self.show
text so let's go ahead and do that so
we'll define um make sure you're in line
correctly define
show
image
again we pass through self
and we're going to say the load so we're
going to load this image we're going to
say load equals capital image so we're
referencing this image that we loaded up
here from pillow
image
dot open
and now we want to open an image so
actually we don't have an image in our
folder here so let me go back to where
we were
this young man doesn't have any images
we can go to
pythonprogramming.net
and we can get an image of my beautiful
mug right here so we'll take the image
from there and put that image in your uh
directory so for me that's actually this
directory so i'll just move that image
right in here
and we'll call this
pick
and it's pic.png for me so move this
over
um
we'll move this down and so we'll open
uh and then what we want to open is uh
whoops
pic dot p n g
and now we're gonna go ahead we'll say
render to render the image and uh we're
gonna do image
tk so again referencing from pillow and
then photo
image this is also reference it's a
function with an image tk
and we want to
render load right this image that we've
opened here
and then um we're going to use labels to
display our image and what labels are
that basically you can use labels
uh to pack in text or images it doesn't
really matter so i'm gonna say img for
image e equals capital label
um and label is a part of tkinter
uh label again self and then we're gonna
say image equals you know so what are we
using we're gonna use this rendered
image
and then we're gonna to say image.image
equals render
and then finally we're going to go image
dot place and we're going to place this
at x equals zero
and y equals zero
okay
and that's it that's all we have to do
the image will be there next thing we
want to do is we'll do define
show
text
again
self
and scroll down a little bit and
uh
for this one
again we use labels only it's a lot
easier this time it's going to be text
equals
label
label
self again and then text equals
hey they're good looking
like that
okay
and then we have to pack it so we do
text.pack and that basically just adds
the text okay so we save that
and that should be all set
so let me do this
let me save and run it now
oh we have a no attribute show text
looks like we probably yeah okay so
i added that show t-e-x-t uh what we ask
for is just so txt so let's try that one
more time
save and run it there we go and now we
can go edit and then show image and
there we go we get this lovely image of
me and then we can show text and that
pops up hey they're good looking
looks like i'm actually saying it to you
so you can
accept that
so now
what we've done is we've got some menu
items here that will show the images or
show the text
but not naturally so it won't be there
normally it's only there if we add it
now
um just as a quick aside if
by whatever for whatever reason you are
finding that the image and text is
already showing up and you just can't
figure it out uh what's happening is
generally if you do like self dot uh
this will probably do itself.show image
empty parameters and then text empty
parameters let me run this real quick
yeah so they're already there so again
i'll just take this moment to explain
how python works as far as when we're
loading things in this sense we've
actually uh called the function
in the initialization so so the command
here
uh what's happening it's a little bit of
a hacky way to run a function but it's
being run nonetheless
even though we've not clicked the
command we're running the function
because we specify empty parameters here
and so this might be really confusing to
some people as far as why this this
might happen but again as we read
initialization window
this function is not running it's only
being defined but then when we go to
display the window and we load in these
rules for the button they're
automatically being run because not only
not anymore are we treating them as a
command but we're treating them as a
function and they run
so anyway i just wanted to cover that
real quick same thing if you
accidentally did something like this on
exit
we could save and run this real quick
and immediately before you even see the
window pop up it says you know are you
sure you want to exit right
so the window never runs
so just uh wanted to talk about that i
imagine maybe someone initially will
will do this in one of the earlier
videos but
anyway i just wanted to cover why that
happens um because again like i said
uh it seems like it's come out of
nowhere but then what i'm getting all
these questions about
referencing functions before they've
been defined so the rules of this are
definitely confusing i understand
i just want to nail that in so anyway
that's going to conclude the dekenter
basics tutorial here again i realize
there are just like infinite things that
we can do uh with tkinter
probably after uh we do a matplotlib
series i've had a lot of requests for me
to do
a combination of graphing
and tkinter well just so happens that
matplotlib actually already uses tkinter
to give you their graph but some people
don't like that they want to maybe
have the gui where you could let's say
type in a stock name and it will graph
that stock like in a very good looking
gui rather than in like a command window
so i had a lot of requests for that so i
probably will show that
down the road afterward do a matplotlib
tutorial series
um for python 3 anyway
um
and then also um
well never mind but anyway the the t the
purposes here was just to show
like some of the basics of
event handling buttons text images and
from here you can really do all kinds of
things you can already make some pretty
great uh guise just with this
information alone
but pretty soon you know people probably
want to add like a text field widget and
all of that and just understand that
these are all basically widgets that
we've already done like a label is a
widget okay and so you can put these
kinds of things um you can use
text fields like little sliders check
boxes all kinds of stuff
and you can store the output of like you
know text fields and all that so there's
like a lot of things that you can do and
maybe i'll expand this tutorial in a
little bit or something if there's a lot
of requests to go further but from here
you should understand the basics of
tkinter and then if you want to do
something specific you can look up the
function for it
and then be able to do it so
anyway that's going to conclude this
little mini series on tkinter on the
basics of python uh if you guys have any
questions or comments feel free to leave
them below as always thanks for watching
thanks for all the support and
subscriptions and until next time